while economic sanctions against russia
are starting to have an impact the
russian ruble has plunged to a record
low dropping more than 30 percent
against the u.s dollar russians are
scrambling to withdraw money from banks
with long queues forming at cash
machines across the country in an
attempt to prop up the ruble russia
central bank
doubled its key interest rate to an
unprecedented 20 percent and ordered
domestic export companies to sell
foreign reserves
sanctions imposed by the u.s and europe
have also largely cut off the country
from the global financial system
european stock markets fell steeply as
the financial sector reacted to the
latest sanctions among those major
russian banks would be kicked out of the
global financial transaction network
swift at a cost not only to russia but
also to its trading partners over the
weekend german chancellor olaf schultz
made it clear that things could get even
worse
let's not kid ourselves putin will not
change his course overnight but very
soon the russian leadership will feel
the high price it is paying
already in the last week the russian
stock market sank by more than 30
percent that shows our sanctions are
working and we reserve the right to
impose further sanctions
so far sanctions against russia include
the exclusion from swift making it
impossible for sanctioned russian banks
to pay for and receive goods from abroad
there are also restrictions on major
banks with immediate consequences the
european subsidiary of russia's
state-owned spare bank is facing
bankruptcy last week's initial sanctions
also included asset freezes and travel
bans for individuals as well as the
blocking of russia's access to
semiconductors computers and other
high-tech products
experts consider the sanctions against
russia harsh and expect them to possibly
[ __ ] the russian economy for years to
come
joining me now in the studio is dw
correspondent uh clifford cooney
clifford let's talk about these the
implications these sanctions uh uh are
having the rubles plummeting first of
all uh what does that mean for the
russian economy
well it's it's a disaster in in many
ways if you the pictures we've just seen
of these queues outside banks tell tell
us so much
um if you imagine that you're a russian
saver an ordinary russian who's got all
their savings in rubles they're worth 30
less today than they were yesterday um
it's 119 rubles to the dollar now so in
that case it's it's a very very serious
problem and you know often when we're
talking about you know the political and
the economic where they overlap i think
it's always with sort of things like
currency values that you really see
the political impact the possible
political impact of this because it's so
strong and prices will rise because it
will force inflation because a lot of
the economy relies on imports which will
now cost more because the ruble is worth
less
so in in these areas you can sort of see
that it's going to have massive impact
um the uh sanctions on the the russian
central bank
is that sort of the the sharpest weapon
that has been employed it is i mean
there's been quite a lot of discussion
about the swift transfer payments uh
system being a
a strong weapon but actually in many
ways the the limitation and the
restrictions on the european central
bank are even tougher because what it
means is that um russia has something
like 630 billion in foreign reserves
which um in the run-up to the invasion
was sort of seen as as um as the war
chest that putin would use for this but
around 40 of those are held overseas and
if they can't access 40 of their
reserves that puts them in into a
difficult position so the restrictions
on the central banks have been a very
important weapon another important
weapon
is of course the exclusion from this
swift banking payment and information uh
system that's used globally
in which way does that affect the um
russian economy yeah well i think the
swift system um is kind of like a
whatsapp where banks talk to each other
on on on a social
it's a communications tool essentially
so while in in many ways it isn't as as
as sharp a weapon as the uh european
central uh sorry the russian central
bank sanctions it's still a very
important one because banks can't talk
to each other which means you can't do
clearing you have to use alternative
systems and that takes time and it costs
money and some people have estimated it
could cost maybe 20 more in terms of
transaction costs so it's it's it's also
something that will completely isolate
the the russian banking system because
so many countries are now sanctioning
the russian banking system that nobody's
going to really bother
putting in an alternative system of
payments so
russian foreign trade at least with the
west really has come more or less to a
standstill now many people have
suggested that uh china uh might be able
to help russia out and buy more gas or
oil
from russia a is that likely uh b is is
china willing to do that
well i think china must be watching this
with with a certain amount of horror
actually um
early in february we had
they signed a pact the new era they were
talking about the close friendship and
then suddenly um
the invasion happened there's a lot of
questions about whether china knew it
was going to happen it's very possible
they did but the fallout from the
invasion is certainly something that
they're going to be aware of and the
question is whether china is prepared to
allow itself by
association um to be also guilty and
whether it's prepared to make that
sacrifice for its uh friends in russia
and i think myself that it's very
unlikely to do that because
um china is is much more
interconnected in global trade
um also china has a lot more power and a
lot more economic muscle than than
russia so i i think if if it becomes a
difficult situation for china to back up
russia as increasingly looks likely i
think they're probably going to hold
back
does
is china in any way dependent on russia
well china china
needs the energy like everyone else um
in europe it seems in that whole land
mass um and that's a big a big aspect um
a lot of a lot of the relationship is
political and they do have close trading
links and traditionally i've had close
trading links um but i think china is in
a much much better position to stand
alone if it needs to i think russia
means china more than china needs russia
clifford couldn't there thank you very
much for this assessment
and as we heard a part of their
sanctions against russia the european
union and its allies have agreed to
block some russian banks from the swift
global payment system the move is widely
regarded as the toughest measure in
trying to put pressure on the russian
economy here's why
what is swift the acronym stands for
society for worldwide interbank
financial telecommunication
a global network founded to process
international financial transactions
it's been around since 1973.
190 countries used the standardized
system as well as banks and commodities
and securities traders last year some 42
million transactions were handled by
swift every day
each swift member is identified by its
bank identifier code or big
the big ensures that money transfers are
paid into the correct account
a big is familiar to anyone with a bank
card
it allows bank a in germany to carry out
transactions with money shares or
precious metals with bank b in the us
if a big code is blocked the member is
shot out of swift barring russia's
access to the swift network would sever
the country completely from the
international monetary flow
russia's companies would no longer be
able to pay for or receive foreign goods
russia's trade with the rest of the
world would be suspended but it means
the trade and urgently needed goods from
russia would also be interrupted the
result rising energy prices worldwide
and russia is not only a major exporter
of oil and gas but of iron and steel too
still being shut out of swift would harm
russia most of all in the catalogue of
sanctions it's the instrument that cuts
the deepest
a pipeline for transporting gas from
poland to lithuania is expected to be
completed ahead of schedule
operator gas systems says it will open
may 1st instead of later in the year as
initially announced auctions for
capacity allocation will begin in april
work has been stepped up amid concerns
about european energy security
now it's normally one of the biggest
events of the year for technology fans
the mobile world congress starts in
barcelona up to 60 000 trade visitors
are expected at the world's largest
mobile communications trade fair but
it's also been overshadowed by the
events in ukraine and the massive
economic sanctions on russia include
something not seen in decades a ban on
technology transfers high-tech companies
at the fair are discussing what that
could mean for them
dw's chelsea delaney is at the mwc in
barcelona she sent us this assessment
well this was expected to be a week of
celebration for the global technology
industry a return to normality after the
pandemic instead the war between russia
and ukraine is really dominating this
event there was supposed to be a russia
pavilion there no longer will be but
there's also a lot of long-term
consequences for the industry that we're
going to see really taking center stage
here first and foremost russia's access
to western technology particularly
semiconductors is going to be restricted
as well russia is a major supplier of
things like palladium or neon that are
crucial to technology production so this
could end up actually worsening some of
these supply chain issues we've been
dealing with at the same time a lot of
western companies like google or
facebook or twitter youtube are seeing
access to their services restricted in
russia or are restricting them
themselves so they're having to
acknowledge that their products are
being used as a weapon as the ukrainian
deputy prime minister said that they're
being used for propaganda to build
influence for uh for censorship so this
is really a landmark moment in which
global technology giants have to really
face their role in geopolitical events
and the outcome of that analysts say is
what they're calling the splinter net
where we see where we see access to
technology access to the internet become
really fractured and no longer this
global connector that we've known it as
you